hi my name is Donna view on the
executive
channel at Princeton University thank
you very much for having me here today
Rick Ehlinger might have described
himself as a recovering archivist I have
to describe myself as a recovering
television news journalist with CNN for
many many years and as a news producer I
had the privilege of talking to many
many people who have given a lot of
thought and research to solving the
problems of the world and I would have
very long discussions with them and it
would all be on tape and then very
tragically I would come back into the
newsroom and throw away about
ninety-five percent what they said so I
was fortunate enough to be offered a
teaching fellowship at Princeton and it
came at a time when the new media was
changing all of the concepts that we old
media people had about delivering news
and information to the public I came to
Princeton there are lots of fantastic
lectures at Princeton I figured I found
out a lot of them were being taped and
that Princeton wasn't was was streaming
some of them on the web but that's about
as far as it went and I thought we are
reaching an age where if you simply
lower the barriers of production you can
admit all this great new content and
then if you lowered the barriers of
distribution you could deliver it back
out to a much broader public than was
ever possible before so the University
Channel is a consortium of public policy
schools many of them have these public
affairs lectures many of them tape them
for archival purposes and as I started
calling around to other universities I
discovered that many of them did not
have
channels of distribution now this is
changing very quickly with the advent of
podcast and all of that many
universities are doing it on their own
but it seemed worthwhile still to pursue
a curated collection of lectures on
Public and International Affairs full
unedited lectures with the live audience
the questions from peers you know
pre-selected by the universities
themselves so that all of the issues of
who is doing the gatekeeping which is
what a lot of institutions of journalism
use as justification for their editorial
policies is taken up now by universities
the concept is very simple it's
essentially a blog the most recent
lectures are on the top they are given
to us to host either depending on
whether it was just taped as audio or
whether it was taped as audio or video
but I'll take a multi formatted example
just to show you we asked the
universities to contribute in the
highest resolution possible because I
think unlike a lot of video online
projects we also distribute through the
internet to television stations for full
blown rebroadcast and this was
definitely not possible back in my days
at CNN because I you know I still
remember in 1989 when the man walked in
front of the tank if any of you remember
that image we had that image on
videotape the only way to feed the
videotape out of China in those days you
had to go through a central Chinese TV
CCTV and of course they weren't going to
let us feed the image so we we fed we
had the the video but you could not
transmit video of a regular phone line
in those days
except pixel-by-pixel so we took one
image and we fed it pixel by pixel over
a phone line and it was received at CNN
Atlanta it took two minutes for the
entire image single still image to feed
and our anchors found the story so
compelling that they were actually
talking about it as the image was
unfolding on the screen live well now we
are feeding to these access stations
many of whom are you know these are
municipal community educational access
stations don't have tremendous resources
some of them still have only dial-up
connections and yet they can ftp an
hour-and-a-half program and then convert
it to whatever their playback format is
and put it out to the local television
audience and we do not ignore the
television audience even though we do
have a large online audience but I still
feel that the television audience is
significant particularly when you're
aiming for overseas distribution so so
we are committed to maintaining our
programming in as higher original
resolution as possible our archives are
in high resolution mpeg-2 and this is
useful for not only television stations
but the new IP TV you know television
over the Internet Protocol a lot of
universities are using this in
recognition of the fact that more
students bring laptops to universities
then bring TVs they are deploying
regular broadcast channels over their IP
networks so that students can watch TV
on their laptops and the University
Channel is there and in
collaboration with campus eai reaching a
potential 40 million within the edu
domain not only in the United States but
but overseas so our distribution is
simple we take one you know give us your
digital file we will transco the the
podcast audience are typical lecture is
downloaded perhaps three thousand times
I feel like you know compared to skype
and google here I feel like the David
following Goliath but I think the I
think we I'm very heartened by by
evidence of who those people are we have
you know about fifteen percent from
overseas ten percent from the edu domain
and those are the statistics but I know
that a lot of people link to our site
from web CT and blackboard so that's
being used as educational materials
we've had k through 12 closed-circuit
people asking us for the high resolution
and PEG tube programming my my Dean Dean
slaughter went to Libya recently and
someone came up to her and said oh thank
you for the University Channel so things
like that really you know warm my heart
because where we are trying to reach us
broad an audience as possible and these
are public lectures to begin with so the
IP issues are greatly simplified for us
because a lot of these people are want
to be heard and if they don't sign a
release and they simply don't show up so
so we're not we're not trying to
persuade professors to to you know let
us film an entire and
course when Apple unveiled the video
iPod we deployed the mpeg-4 format and
with all of the new formats that come up
I mean I'm reminded you know I'm old
enough to remember the television feed
rooms in remote capitals around the
world where you had a whole Bank of you
know outlets to suit all the different
formats and all the different machinery
that that foreign news crews might bring
in and I feel actually we're somewhat in
the same in the same field now only
we're dealing with codecs and and you
know lines of code and the goal is the
same the goal is to get the the content
out to to the public now a lot of these
universities who have joined us there's
no it's completely lon exclusive
distribution we're distributing under
Creative Commons with attribution non
derivative license is the one we chose
and a lot of the schools have all this
material on their own websites and that
is fine that is good but i think we
provide the additional value of having a
single go-to spot for the discussion of
Public and International Affairs and so
for example Stephen Bosworth who is the
Dean of Fletcher might be speaking at
LBJ in Texas and everyone benefits from
the fact that all these schools are
providing their material to a common
place so that the much broader
discussion say of events
Iraq you know climate change etc are
accessible from the single search and
that is pretty much